Sometimes when Donald Trump does something,
we call it humiliating, but it's only humiliating
if you have a certain sensibility.
It's only humiliating if you have a certain
world view.
Donald Trump last night gave an interview
to Fox News's Sean Hannity that was so cringeworthy,
so disgusting, that the humiliation has spread
much farther than you can imagine.
Sean Hannity actually brought up the story
of Donald Trump allegedly calling dead soldiers
who died in combat suckers and the losers.
And Donald Trump focused in on the idea that
it's not true, that he didn't want to be out
in the rain in France, and that that's part
of why Donald Trump didn't go, that Donald
Trump says, I've been out in the rain many
times and my hair gets wet and it's no big
deal.
This is the level of discussion that is happening
with the president of the United States on
one of the top rated cable news shows.
We have a raging pandemic with nearly 200000
deaths.
We have all sorts of economic problems.
We are on the precipice of a major election.
And Donald Trump is on cable news saying it's
okay if my hair gets wet.
I made a speech in the rain.
No umbrellas, no anything.
You know, they said just this information.
I didn't want to get my hair wet.
I've had my hair wet plenty of times.
I made plenty of speeches in the rain.
And if I wasn't, if I didn't, you wouldn't
be president right now.
That I can tell you.
So it's disinformation.
They made up a story about two disgusting
words that they say.
I said and I didn't.
And I have many witnesses.
We have twenty one witnesses.
They only have sources.
Of course, Trump doesn't seem to realize that
a witness to something saying you didn't say
it is a weird thing if someone comes forward
and says, I didn't hear Trump say it.
That's not proof.
It wasn't said.
All it means is you didn't hear it.
And it's it's very difficult, of course, to
prove a negative.
That's by it.
By its very nature.
Hard to do.
Donald Trump doesn't seem to get that.
And he insists, listen, Zach said some guy
named Zach Zach said, I didn't say it.
Well, that just means he didn't hear you say
it.
Earlier this week, I reported to you that
Donald Trump's campaign is tight on cash.
They have had to slow down ad spending in
some key states.
The fundraising is a problem.
And Sean Hannity, this is I mean, this is
how you turn manure into gold or at least
attempt to.
Sean Hannity hilariously asked, Donald Trump
is not buying ads.
A strategy like is not having money, maybe
a strategy, even check this out.
Say that is not the case.
Yeah, little shy of 300 million dollars.
But I was told by a friend in Florida that
that Joe Biden has three to one ads running
against Jaws.
Is this a strategy you're waiting or is this
something that you didn't want?
Maybe you're just ramping up after Labor Day.
So four years ago, I wanted in the last month
and we have about three times more cash now
than we had then.
And that's without me putting up any of I
needed extra.
I'll put it up myself.
I just said that two days ago.
I said if there's any necessary extra cash,
but we have a lot of money coming in and small
donors.
I haven't been heavy on big donors because
I don't want to call them.
You know, when you call big donors, you you
sort of put yourself in a very compromising
position.
Trump knows how compromising it is to get
money from donors because he spent the last
four years doing favors to his donors.
And it's very interesting to hear Donald Trump
say we won it in the last month in 2016.
This is not a guarantee of anything.
Of course, Joe Biden's lead today, today is
seven point.
Five nationally, Hillary's lead on this day
in 2016 was two point seven.
So today, Joe Biden's lead is nearly three
times as large as Hillary's was at this time
in 2016.
It doesn't mean Trump is going to lose.
But Trump saying this year is just like 2016
is assuming a lot in 2016.
Donald Trump was not already the president
in 2016.
Donald Trump was much closer to his opponent
than where he is today.
That those are just factual differences.
Then Donald Trump goes on to say that right
now the United States has a record number
of jobs.
What that means is a question.
We don't know what they're doing, frankly,
but they should all be open.
And our country is doing very well.
We have record numbers of jobs.
You saw the numbers just came out for the
four months.
It's the largest number ever by far.
Not even close.
So we do not have a record number of jobs
right now.
Donald Trump has no idea what he's talking
about.
Remember that the big picture numbers are
we lost close to 50 million jobs during the
pandemic.
Many of those have come back.
OK, but we are still way down.
The idea that we have more jobs than ever
is something that you have a tough time convincing
a 12 year old of even a smart nine year old
probably wouldn't fall for it.
But Donald Trump throws out this generality.
We have the record number of jobs.
It's very much untrue.
You're not going to hear any fact checking
of it from Sean Hannity.
And then also continuing to spread what at
this point is just embarrassing disinformation.
Donald Trump claiming that if you look at
our coronavirus numbers, that they're actually
amazing.
It's just incredible how well we've done.
There's two million, two and a half million,
maybe even more than that, if we did it a
different way and we've done a really good
job.
But if you look at our numbers, our fatality
numbers compared to other countries we're
in, we're in.
Really I mean, it's amazing what we've done.
We've been able to do something that a country,
especially with the kind of size we're dealing
with, we've done an incredible job.
The truth there, of course, is our numbers
are really, really bad.
Now, if you don't adjust for our population,
the U.S. has by far the most coronavirus deaths.
But we also have a lot of people we really
need to be looking at per capita numbers on
a per capita basis.
The United States is 11th highest in the world.
Out of more than 200 countries and territories
in terms of deaths per capita.
Now, if you take out some of these tiny countries
and territories, which can skew the numbers
like San Marino and Andorra, the United States
has the ninth highest deaths per capita from
Corona virus in the world.
It's not the lowest.
It's not in the bottom half.
It is the ninth highest in the world.
Question to you, when Trump says this stuff,
when Trump says we have more jobs than ever.
When Trump says we have the best corona virus
numbers in the world.
Do people believe it?
Are there people who hear Trump say it and
think Trump's right?
We've done such a great job.
We're so much better off than every other
country.
Or is it just something he has to say, even
if no one is going to believe it?
I actually don't know the answer.
I know there are people who do think we're
doing well on the virus, but I don't know
that they think it because Donald Trump is
the one saying it.
Let me know your thoughts.
And bigger picture.
Does an interview like this do trump any favors?
Is this a net gain for Trump in some way to
be interviewed by Sean Hannity, even if he
makes no sense in ways that I can't exactly
understand?
Does this do damage or does it really not
make a difference whatsoever?
If you look at the sort of framework of Allan
Lichtman, who predicts elections using a qualitative
rather than quantitative system, he would
argue, I think, that this doesn't matter,
that really what impacts the election are
big issues.
What is the status of the economy?
Is there a major calamity, et cetera?
There are others who may have a different
perspective.
Let me know in general, do interviews like
this have any impact on the election result?
We would expect.